here's 17 things you missed in departure
the 2011 hunt Hunter anime opening given
that this opening ran for almost 150
episodes straight the production team
made sure to utterly stuff it with
enough detail that repeat viewings would
be very rewarding and even after
watching it 148 times there is
definitely stuff you missed so the very
first thing you see in the departure
opening is Heaven's arena in fact the
first three departure openings are
sandwi by Heaven's Arena content on both
sides we see it in the distance at the
very beginning and at the end we've
reached gone confronting Hoka and the
reason why Heaven's Arena gets used so
much is because it's not just the
physical destination we're working
towards and it's not just building up
towards gon's confrontation with hisoka
in the grand scheme of hun Hunter that's
almost a sid trip the reason why this
building is ever present is because
Heaven's Arena represents the true final
stage of the hunter exam which is the
secret nen teaching phase so even though
it does feel a bit weird to always have
Heaven's arena in sight well well before
it becomes relevant it represents what
gone and in fact what everyone else is
working towards in the first 36 episodes
for the first few openings the fall
protagonists are also accompanied by
text which is the language of the hunt
Hunter world so in order to translate it
what you need to do is first need to
translate that text into Japanese and
then that Japanese into English it's
actually not that difficult because it's
a very simplistic writing system that
acts as a onetoone replacement of
hiragana so no kakor and very
importantly no kanji so that makes the
hunter hunter language very friendly and
in the openings these end up spelling
the full names of the characters or at
least the full ones of the ones we know
but even if you can't read Japanese or
hunt
there is at least one letter that you
recognize because if we look at leorio's
name we see two circles now in English
this sort of circle that would be an O
and in this language it is also an O
although evidently Japanese itself does
exist in the hunt Hunter world as in the
Chimera Anar opening Isaac net gets
plastered with a nice big kanji which
can be read as either Shin or kokoro and
has a wide array of meanings including
Spirit heart mind feelings and emotion
essentially this is the closest a single
kanji con coved covering the the entire
Human Experience which is why netro
Brands himself with it marching into the
extermination Mission as a champion of
humanity and that's also why he gets
stamped with the kanji in this opening
the kanji itself is also what the ants
mainly struggle with during the sck
netro isn't their toughest opponent the
humanity within the answers also this
fictional Hunter content is sponsored by
ug green the company that continues to
specialize in making my life easier not
just by sponsoring these videos but by
catering to my voracious power needs in
fact this is the third time we've worked
with ug GRE now and keeps sending me
this stupidly useful stuff so this time
I have the honor of showing off the nexo
pro 65 wat mini as well as the nexo pro
65w cookie the cookie in particular I
love because it's so slim unbelievably
light and it has two USBC ports and one
usba a port the USB C1 can provide 65
wats of charging power and it can charge
a 13in MacBook Air from 0 to 70% in 60
minutes and the mini can do exactly the
same thing just in a much more cuter
chome size both come equipped with nex's
revolutionary aarch combined with the
latest scan Infinity chip which allows
these bad boys to be as small as they
are so for example I also have the much
larger four port 160 W option which is
also amazing but more often than not I
find that these little guys get the job
done just as well and each of them can
charge up to three devices at once as
well as be compatible with 45 W Samsung
super fast charging 2.0 which is
fantastic for me because I run a
production office with laptops phones
earbuds and camera batteries just
batteries for days man so I can never
ever ever have enough of these so you
can and should check out my link in the
descript to acquire these amazing
devices and it directly supports the
channel because it's sponses like you
green that allow us to support our
Channel artists and editors and
generally give us the power to bring you
more content more regularly so thanks
again to you green but for now it's back
to you me but one of the things I love
about the very first departure opening
is that we get to see our four
protagonists do exactly that and within
seconds it tells you everything you need
to know about them gone actually begins
at the very last part of the first stage
of the hunter exam but it symbolizes him
feeling trapped on whale Island and
having the whole world open up to him as
he exits the tunnel kopaka is running
through a very natural environment
because he grew up in the natural
Wonderland that was the luo province sad
it's not so great anymore and you've got
Loria running through a miscellaneous
slum Town they're always very hard to
distinguish from one another because
Togashi has this very established slum
style that he falls back on but the
reason why he's in this environment is
because Leorio grew up in poverty and he
even had a friend die because he
couldn't afford surgery that would have
saved his life so Leorio he's leaving
all of this behind to pursue both wealth
and and medicine to ensure that this
never happens again and then we see
kilaa skating away from Heaven's Arena
which is interesting because that's the
destination that everyone else is
portrayed as running towards so this
cost Kila as the more experienced one
because this is the destination that
everyone else in the opening is running
towards but one that kilawa has already
comfortably conquered to the point where
he can just casually skate away from it
and it's very funny because literally
the next shot is all four protagonist
running towards Heaven's Arena so From
kilo's perspective he's skating away and
then he sees his friends and it's all
like oh okay I guess I'm going back but
going back to kap's departure though
there's a lot more here than most people
realizing including me this was actually
pointed out to me by a channel called
sash MASH which sadly I don't think is
active anymore but this channel made an
amazing video dissecting departure from
a musical perspective a link to which is
in the description and one small thing
sash smash lingered on is copica running
into the falling green leaves falling
leaves is a very common piece of imagery
to indicate death the month of autumn or
fall for American friends is
historically known as a Time of Dying
and Rising hence why in say Catholicism
they celebrate both All Saints Day and
All Souls day in Autumn one celebrates
the souls that have reached the heaven
and one celebrates the souls that have
departed but have not yet reached the
heaven I think I'm not Catholic that's
what Google said so the tone is somber
but celebratory however in kpa's case
this comes with a particularly painful
twist because he's running into falling
green leaves green generally meaning
alive and can thus symbolize a premature
death and he's running into a a whole
lot of them one might even say that
there's an entire clan of leaves
representing his sled curter Brethren
and you know what you could also view it
as kopaa symbolically running
prematurely towards his own death
because he's going into the leaves
because from the very commencement of
hunt Hunter until the conclusion of yoru
kapica considers his life more or less
forfeit the only reason why he exists at
this stage is to kill the Phantom troop
and one painfully minor touch that I
also love is that kopa is frowning the
whole time whilst running which is then
directly ju's pose against Leorio
running with a big old grin on his face
I love it because it shows how each of
them have decided to deal with their
respective grief karapa he's chosen the
path of causing more pain so much more
pain whil Leorio is doing his best to
transform his ordeal into something
positive but after watching this opening
roughly a gazillion times one of the
things that makes me laugh is the part
where kilaa steps in to defeat all of
the enemies in front of gone the first
one is dispatched with a really cool and
rather painful kick to the back of the
head but the other guy has a much
weirder fate because if you look very
carefully what Kila does is playfully
kick him in the elbow and it sends him
flying so so far it's just a piece of
choreography that I find interesting
that probably no one else does like Kow
just does this this dainty kick and the
guy gets hit in the elbow and he's like
ah flying away but look I do personally
pay a lot of attention to kila in these
openings because for most of them you
can tell the entire story through his
eyes alone in the first departure he
pops in and his eyes are immediately
fixated on gone and when they're both
running down Heaven Arena there's this
super quick but split second of Kila
looking towards gon and making sure that
he's having fun as well then at the end
of the Greed Island opening you've got
both gon and Kila looking at each other
which is a big step forward because this
is the strongest their friendship gets
as opposed to the end of the Chimera
Anar opening where not only is kilan not
looking at gone for the first time but
they're both facing away from each other
because they're going down very
different paths out of context it does
look quite statuesque and stoic as if
they're both determined to see this
through and they are but each of them
has a very different idea IDE of how
this situation needs to play out and so
the two of them can no longer see eye to
eye and then in the final opening gone
and kilawa aren't even on screen
together at all except for right at the
beginning where you see gone walking
away from kiloa and his Focus then
shifts to aluka who becomes his new
companion from this point onwards for
such a cold brutal assassin man kila's
eyes alone Express so much more emotion
than almost any other character as a
whole and I think that the openings did
a brilliant job of utilizing that as
well as many other things because visual
language is everything in the first
opening there's a brief Montage of three
groups that we encountered during the
hunter exam the first is Hoka and ILY
and they look incredibly intimidating
because the camera is looking up at them
they occupy a higher plane of existence
than us and they aren't even looking
straight at us half of their faces are
also obscured as if they're not
particularly concerned with our presence
and of course they're draped in
delightful dark purple which is one of
the more spiritual colors indicating
wisdom or Divinity but also dark purple
in particular is used to indicate an
obstacle to be overcome then we move to
a group shot of the the other Hunter
exam candidates and they immediately
look far less intimidating because
they're all looking at the camera flat
on and most of them are also meeting our
eyeline all in all they're not too much
to be worried about however they're set
against a red and this paints them as
the most immediate danger the biggest
danger is Hoka and dilam they're the
ones that ultimately we need to keep an
eye on and be worried about but these
lesser dangers are the most immediate
thread they're the ones currently going
for our throats so we need to give them
attention as well and finally we have
the set of examiners who like isoka and
dilam are also looking down on the
camera especially netro who's perched on
a Communications Tower which represents
the gulf between the chairman and even
seasoned Hunters because so tots meni
and bhara they're all meant to be looked
up to that they're meant to be presented
as achievable but overall this group is
assigned yellow which is the color of
idealism imagination optimism hope and
all of the other good words and also
some of the bad ones like hazards which
the examiners definitely are it's not
their job to not kill you if that makes
sense now the first time we see the
Phantom troop is opening too and they're
covered in a collage that forms from the
top down ending with croo at the very
bottom and this is really cool visual
language because generally you'll find
that in anime when showcasing enemies
like this there's this tendency to put
the leader at the top but the fact that
CR is on the bottom creates an image
where he quite literally has the rest of
the Phantom troop on his shoulders which
he metaphorically does as their leader
it says that they mean something to him
and that crlo does feel the weight of
their lives as opposed to them being
minions to prop up his evil empire then
in the third opening we have a very cool
Montage of the troop using their
abilities one small detail I like is
that we get a glimpse of vinx using rip
ayron long long before he actually uses
it in the series but the only troop
member who doesn't get a showcase is uin
who has a solo shot accompanied by the
lyrics you can smile which if you didn't
know any better would paint uin as the
tragic protagonist because he's lit by
these beautiful pristine rays of light
and so it makes you think that he's
someone who fell in battle making a
noble sacrifice and I guess from the
perspective of the Phantom troop that's
exactly what he did and I I just find it
really interesting that this moral
ambiguity gets incorporated into
openings because it shows that the
production team have put a lot of
thought into this to someone who doesn't
know Hunter Hunter this could very
easily be a compilation of protagonists
protagonist attacking in the name of
their fallen brother and this sort of
respect continues very much into the
fourth opening where we see a group shot
of the Phantom troop standing on a
symbol that you may or may not
immediately recognize but it's the
cross-shaped tattoo on cr's forehead now
CR himself as always carries quite a bit
of religious symbolism Hunter Hunter
which I think this opening reflects
perfectly because despite C's absence
from The Troop you have this shot of his
disciples standing proudly on his symbol
to carry on his ideals every tiny part
of these openings thought out almost
Beyond reasonable belief such is the end
of opening four where there's a nice
shot of all the Greed Island Gear with
what looks like an assortment of random
cards dropped on the table but even
these cards have been meticulously
chosen so three cards in particular
you've got map of the island Peak and
sword of truth all of which are geared
towards revealing and or obtaining
information which is the entire reason
why gone is on Greed Island he's on a
quest to find information about his
father that's why these cards hold more
weight than the others which are flipped
around because we're disregarding them
but the other visible card is my
favorite Greed Island card Rock which is
just a simple Rock in card form and it
might seem arbitrary but it's absolutely
intentional because rock is the first n
ability that gone develops during this
Arc to the ants now something that's
always stood out to me about the Chimera
ant Arc opening is the beginning where
we have maram underwater rising to the
surface and eventually above the planet
itself and I believe this is to mimic
the path of human evolution because we
started out as aquatic organisms as well
but in maro's case he goes straight from
water to above the planet which
represents how rapidly he evolved beyond
the human species and when we first see
the royal guard they get introduced in
the order in which they were born but
they end up occupying very interesting
spaces in the shot where they bow to
maram you've got shyia in the background
whose expression is the hardest to make
out and ultimately he's the most
untrustworthy one and furthest away from
the king's ideology second furthest
physically away is yupi who's a step
closer to maram but nowhere near as
close as Pito who was on level ground
and was always perfectly in sync with
the king's desires so this image shows
your varying PLS of loyalty each of the
royal God were fiercely loyal but UPI
and shyia were a few steps removed in
the final opening we're treated to a
montage of the zodiacs who seem like
they're arranged in random groups but
they're ordered chronologically
according to the Chinese zodiac animals
for example the first four animals are
rat Ox tiger and rabbit also known as
pariston misom Kanai and peon and
finally the ending of the last opening
is the only one that doesn't feature
gone in the closing shot instead it ends
with Jing on top of the world tree
symbolizing that gone story has for all
intense and purposes concluded and that
we're moving on to something new which
is further symbolized by gone passing on
the license which was the inciting
object for the entire series and that's
17 things that you probably missed in
the hunter hunter openings